so we have another data point in our
building belief that Ron DeSantis simply
is not ready for prime time and would
completely fail if he did try to run
against Donald Trump in the Republican
primary which is not yet a foregone
conclusion we're still going to have to
wait and see whether DeSantis chooses to
get into this race a campaign for
DeSantis that is rapidly collapsing
before it even starts Ron DeSantis had a
complete and total meltdown when asked
about this former Guantanamo Bay
Detention Center detainee who has
claimed that DeSantis observed when he
was being tortured now DeSantis for a
long time has been saying no no no no no
I wasn't I wasn't in any position of
power at the time or whatever and
DeSantis just flips out here and again
you can tell he is not ready to be
confronted with tough questions by
journalists I don't think if this is how
he reacts to a simple question and gets
so heated and triggered I don't see how
he could possibly succeed on a debate
stage with Donald Trump check this out
the latest DeSantis off the handle
how would they know me okay think about
that do you honestly believe that's
credible so this is 20 2006 I'm a junior
officer do you honestly think that they
would have remembered me from Adam of
course not they're just trying to get
into the news because they know people
like you will consume it because it fits
your pre-ordained narrative that you're
trying to spend focus on the facts
attacking the person asking the question
about newsworthy claims that have been
made is not going to get you a lot of
supporters in many circles including
Republican circles a better thing to do
would be to answer the question
substantively the problem is that in
2018 DeSantis also was asked about this
and he sure made it sound like he was
very much involved in what was going on
at Guantanamo Bay in a facility so it's
limited but some of the things they
would do they would do hunger strikes
and you actually had three detainees
that committed suicide with hunger
strike so everything at that time was
legal in nature one way or another so
the commander wants to know well how do
I combat this so one of the jobs of the
legal advisor would be like hey you
actually can force feed here's what you
can do here's kind of the rules of that
wow he certainly seems to know super
specifically the exact number of people
that were subjected to this that or the
other thing and says he was weighing in
with opinions about exactly what to do
that so during the feeding a group of
officers arrived with the interpreters
with the interrogators
they were behind the fence
and I saw one of them was Randy Santos
in a military uniform
and he was while I was screaming yelling
because I couldn't breathe of the insure
and was like I was bleeding because they
really insert the effect to you through
my nose
so I was like calling them asking and
they he was actually laughing looking at
the other officers and smiling all right
now could this guy be lying absolutely
absolutely but the totality of how
DeSantis is handling these questions
given his eagerness to show how
specifically he knew about every detail
of what was being done there do we
believe that on a place as small as
Guantanamo Bay DeSantis would have been
advising about exactly what to do and
yet never present at these events very
difficult to believe cut to now getting
angry at the reporter for even asking
the question he is not ready for prime
time I hope that he does run because
it's abundantly clear that his campaign
would be a complete and total
humiliating mess maybe he can mess up
Trump's campaign to some degree but as
far as a serious presidential candidate
DeSantis is truly lacking if you or one
of your parents is starting to lose your
hearing you're not alone about 48
million Americans have hearing loss and
only one in five people who would
benefit from using a hearing aid are
actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearing's new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special special deal for my audience
when you buy a pair of hearing aids
you'll get them for just 149.99 each
plus they'll include a free extra
charging case go to mdhearing.com and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below